aquí tenemos otra vez una compañía
supongamos que es una fábrica de
artesanías una vez más a una compañía de
artesanías y lo que voy a hacer es
escribir su estado de resultados por
varios años lo que hicimos en el primer
vídeo de esta serie simplemente fue
escribir un estado de resultados verdad
una fotografía creo que fue de 2008 pero
aquí estamos viendo el estado de
resultados de varios años en este caso
estoy suponiendo que tienen un ingreso
de ventas muy estable entonces cada año
tienen la misma cantidad de ingreso en
ventas ahora su costo de bienes vendidos
déjame separarlo esta vez porque hay dos
componentes en el costo de bienes
vendidos déjame ponerle aquí
costo de bienes vendidos o sea cobro el
costo de bienes vendidos pero algunas
veces puedes ver que la gente lo abre
había como cobertura bueno costo de
bienes vendidos entonces número uno hay
costos variables este no es un vídeo de
las diferencias entre costos variables y
costos fijos pero sería bueno aprender
un poquito al respecto de eso pero bueno
tenemos costos variables y eso
literalmente es el costo bueno en lo que
tuvimos que pagar para hacer las
artesanías no sé si están hechas de
madera entonces es el dinero para
comprar la madera
para pagar el recibo de electricidad
para moldearla para darle la forma para
pintarla todo lo que tuviste que hacer
para hacerlas entonces supongamos que el
costo variable de cada uno de estos años
y nos estoy suponiendo que el costo de
madera no cambia mucho es de digamos 100
mil pesos menos 100 mil pesos menos 100
mil pesos menos 100 mil pesos por año
menos 100 mil pesos y supongamos que
aquí también tenemos el costo de los
empleados ya sabes este su salario que
están pues moldeando estas artesanías
que le están dando esos acabados y todo
esto incorpora ya todo pero ahora en el
costo fijo vamos a poner el costo de la
fábrica pues supongamos que estas
fábricas para hacer artesanías se tienen
que rehacer cada dos años o sea que
necesitan reparaciones así muy grandes
cada dos años entonces vamos a ponerle
que las reparaciones de la fábrica
porque otras partes del costo verdad de
hacer las artesanías así que bueno
supondremos que si uno sigue haciendo
artesanías y artesanías así con este
ritmo 2 en la fábrica tiene que
repararse cada dos años
déjame ponerlo por aquí como un costo
fijo reparación de fábrica
preparación de fábrica ahora en la
mayoría de las ocasiones no vas a ver
que en un estado de resultados se paren
los gastos así pues puede haber varias
razones a lo mejor la fábrica de
artesanías no quiere que la competencia
vea cómo es el esquema de costos no le
quieren dar mucha información o también
puede ser que la fábrica no quiera que
los clientes vean en qué se está
gastando pero bueno preparación de
fábrica la forma en la cual acabo de
describir las reparaciones nos sugiere
una forma para hacer la contabilidad
esto es que cuando hacemos la reparación
de fábrica esencialmente lo pones como
un gasto pues supongamos que la
reparación de fábrica costó 500 mil
pesos
voy a poner por aquí es menos 500 mil
pesos pero se tiene que hacer nada más
cada dos años verdad entonces se hizo en
el 2005 no se tiene que hacer en el 2006
pero tienen que hacerlo en 2007 - 500
mil pesos en 2008 no muy bien ahora
tenemos la utilidad bruta déjame
escribirla por aquí tenemos la utilidad
bruta
fruta
ok entonces aquí es un millón menos 100
600 mil pesos es 400 mil pesos luego
aquí es 900 mil pesos a cada vuelve a
ser 400 mil pesos y en 2008 es 900 mil
pesos y ahora vamos a poner vejez y
vejez ya voy a poner aquí su vejez ya
recuerda qué vejez ya es ventas general
y administrativo ahorita vamos a suponer
que no se gasta nada en marketing va
pero supongamos que de vejez ya es otros
500 mil pesos cada año le voy a poner
por aquí que es menos 500 mil pesos eso
nunca cambia menos 500 mil pesos cada
año muy bien menos 500 mil ok entonces
su utilidad operativa o sea el ingreso
antes de impuestos bueno también hay que
considerar cómo están financiados verdad
pero pues podemos pensar su utilidad
operativa como su bebito o su ingreso
operativo porque no va a tener intereses
entonces su utilidad operativa en este
año es de menos
pesos aquí también es menos cien mil
pesos pero en 2006 y en 2008 si ganaron
dinero hicieron 400 mil pesos de
ganancia y 400 mil pesos y bueno vamos a
ver suponemos que aquí ya se acaba que
no tiene nada de interés no hay nada de
interés verdad porque ese no es el punto
de este vídeo la siguiente línea es
ingresos antes de impuestos o bien
utilidad antes de impuestos va a ser lo
mismo que la utilidad operativa entonces
es menos 100 mil pesos menos 100 mil
tiene estos años de por acá son 400.000
y 400.000 ok ahora supongamos además que
no se vive en el caribe no tiene que
pagar nada de impuestos porque otra vez
no es el punto
digo podrías aplicar el impuesto sobre
la renta de 30 por ciento pero el punto
más bien es que aunque el negocio es
súper estable y que hacen exactamente lo
mismo cada año verdad cuando nos fijamos
en el valor del ingreso antes de
impuestos o la utilidad operativa vemos
que es un negocio pues así pues no se
superen súper inestable un año pierden
100 mil pesos verdad podemos decir que
negocio tan más horrible pero al
siguiente año ganan 400.000 luego
pierden 100 mil y entonces uno puede
decir así como puede ser o sea es un
negocio súper estable que su cobertura y
su ingreso de ventas es el mismo en el
transcurso de los años porque su ingreso
es tan variable y creo que ya sabes
verdad tiene mucho que ver con esto de
aquí que son las reparaciones de fábrica
de 500 mil pesos que se hacen pues un
año sí y un año no para reparar la
fábrica y que pueda seguir
en artesanías
bueno entonces la pregunta seria esta es
una buena forma de hacer la contabilidad
donde ella sabes supongo que se podría
decir tienes que comprar nuevo equipo
este 500 estos 500 miligramos que es
para comprar pues nuevas herramientas
para moldear mi madera entonces es una
buena idea hacer la contabilidad
únicamente en el periodo en el que lo
gastaste porque no es como que
simplemente estés usando las
herramientas en ese periodo las estás
usando por dos años entonces la
respuesta de después no sea no es una
buena idea porque todo el propósito de
la contabilidad que es dar pues una
imagen muy muy precisa a las personas
que están leyendo el estado de
resultados una imagen muy precisa del
negocio pero esto de aquí en mi opinión
no es tan preciso verdad da una
apariencia de mucha inestabilidad de
mucha volatilidad aunque el negocio sea
súper súper estable y aburrido pero
bueno lo que hace es que en vez de decir
a tuve que comprar 500 mil pesos en la
herramienta en 2005 y entonces lo pongo
como un gasto y luego no lo tuve que
hacer en 2006-2007 si en vez de hacer
eso lo que hago es pues
fíjate lo voy a poner aquí abajo bueno
aquí abajo voy a poner una hoja de
balance y entonces como quiera que sea
la hoja de balance
que puesto en la hoja de balance en 2007
déjame dibujar ambos lados de la hoja de
balance
entonces aquí a la izquierda voy a poner
el activo de la hoja de balance en 2007
déjame ponerlo un poco más grueso
entonces esta de aquí es la hoja de
balance este es el lado del activo
entonces deja de poner por acá también
el lado de pasivo está ok entonces en
2007 antes de que gastáramos esos 500
mil pesos verdad justo antes justo antes
de hacerlo pues posiblemente tenía 500
mil pesos de efectivo verdad para pagar
déjame escribirlo aquí efectivo para
poner una e 500 mil pesos eso es un
activo ahora en vez de simplemente
utilizar esto pues para hacer un gasto
después nos vamos a meter en los
detalles de la contabilidad de los
créditos y débitos pero bueno en vez de
utilizar esos 500 mil pesos en gastar
los en vez de eso vamos a transferirlos
a la compra de un activo entonces fíjate
cuando utilizas efectivo para comprar un
activo y ese activo tiene una cierta
vida útil que dura más de un periodo
esencialmente estamos capitalizando el
gasto o bien estamos creando un activo
en la hoja de balance en vez de tener
estos 500 mil pesos desapareciendo en un
gasto ahora tenemos una fábrica
efe que vale 500 mil pesos o bueno
herramientas de la fábrica el efectivo
se va entonces el activo de valor total
no va a haber cambiado simple
los 500 mil de efectivos los
transferimos a herramientas de la
fábrica bueno entonces esto podría ser
al principio de cuando hacemos todo esto
verdad supongamos que este es el primero
de enero de 2007 muy bien ahora lo que
vamos a decir es bueno vamos a utilizar
estas herramientas de la fábrica que se
pueden usar por dos años y entonces
vamos a depreciar las herramientas la
forma de pensarlo es la siguiente en vez
de tener un gasto por reparación de
fábrica déjame tachar le vamos a ponerle
depreciación de la fábrica
depreciación de la fábrica no sé si se
ve ahí muy bien es de prs y ha sido en
depreciación ok entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es repartir el costo de esos 500
mil pesos en la vida útil de este gasto
entonces aquí tenemos 500 mil pesos en
gasto verdad pero en vez de ponerlo aquí
como la mitad se usa un año y la mitad
del otro año en vez de poner 500 mil
pesos aquí la depreciación sería de 250
mil pesos
de modo similar en este año pues no sale
nada de efectivo verdad no sale nada
efectivo por la puerta pero el equipo se
hace viejito usamos otra mitad es menos
250.000 y luego mi equipo no vale nada
verdad entonces esto ya que es primero
enero de 2000
tengo esta herramienta espera que hay
algo raro no creo que no es 2007
más bien es
a ver jamás checar las cosas maquillar a
2005 perdón me equivoqué aquí es 1 de
enero de 2006 entonces lo que voy a
haber hecho es usado la mitad de la
herramienta de modo que la hoja de
balance déjame copiarla y pegarla copiar
pegar bueno se me pasó un poquito de la
fecha bueno se entiende verdad es el
primero de enero de 2006 a 2005 a 2006
entonces ahora voy a haber usado la
mitad de esa fábrica estoy acá ya no
sería 500 mil verdad de acuerdo con la
contabilidad este equipo ya no vale 500
mil sino que vale 250 mil pesos muy bien
y pues sí tiene sentido verdad a lo
mejor se intentará vender mi fábrica en
el mercado abierto me dirían sabes que
sólo vale 250 mil porque ya usaste un
año de su vida útil o sea la mitad
entonces nada más te voy a pagar 250 mil
los otros 250 mil pues eso sí los
escribimos como un gasto que se llama
depreciación entonces cada año lo que le
va a pasar a este activo es que su valor
va a disminuir 250 mil pesos
ok entonces aquí al principio verdad al
principio de este año el activo vale 500
mil déjame escribirlo acá arriba lo voy
a poner con este color naranja verdad
voy a poner cuánto vale el activo
entonces aquí al principio de 2005 el
activo vale 500 mil al final vale 250
mil luego el activo no vale nada pero
tenemos que comprar otro y entonces vale
500 mil de aquí vale 250 mil vale
entonces esta es una forma razonable
pero que es más o menos enredada de
simplemente decir que estamos haciendo
la contabilidad estamos marcando los
gastos repartiendo los a través de la
vida útil esta repartición se llama la
depreciación de un activo
ahorita se me está acabando el tiempo en
este vídeo pero en el siguiente vídeo
voy a hablar de otra palabra similar que
es amortización amortización simplemente
es repartir el costo pero ahora de un
activo que no sea tangible por ejemplo
la depreciación es para fábricas porque
se hacen viejas son gastos físicos
eso es depreciación y bueno si refleja
muy bien lo que está sucediendo en el
negocio o sea aquí no tuve no es como
que no tuviera ningún costo si tuve un
costo porque me estoy
gastando mi fábrica verdad entonces lo
escribo aquí amortización es exactamente
la misma cosa que depreciación solo que
aplica al equipo que no sea pues físico
bueno implica aplica como a patentes o
aplica digamos a una gran deuda oa un
gran financiamiento puede ser que el
financiamiento pues nos traiga un
beneficio que se reparte en el
transcurso de los años entonces lo
registramos así en fin nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo